it's one thing to be lauded as being at
the top of your profession but it's a
different sort of mind that belongs to
someone who can just quit for a while
because they think they've already
solved all the problems and answered all
of the discussions in their field that's
exactly what Ludvig vikander Stein did
after he published his Tractatus
logico-philosophicus in 1922 it would be
the only book had published in his
lifetime and with it he was convinced
that he'd finished the discussion about
philosophy so he did what anyone would
do after they finished they quit his
iotus it wouldn't last long but it's a
fascinating glimpse into the man who
would be remembered as one of the 20th
century's greatest philosophers he was a
self-loathing genius a man born into
wealth and the aristocracy and then who
knew all too well what it was like to
have everything taken away in the blink
of an eye he was a man who gave away a
lot of money fought and lived through
World Wars saw the darkest side of human
nature and through it all he struggled
to make sense of it he may not have
solved all of the problems of philosophy
but he definitely gave the world
something to think about
[Music]
lewd vid Vick consign was the youngest
of a very wealthy family but that's not
to say that he belongs to old money
his father Carl was the son of a wool
merchant and spent his early life much
like the rest of us rebelling against
his own father's wishes and working some
strange odd jobs before finally falling
into where he needed to be at one point
even headed to the US with nothing but a
violin hoping to make a living as an
entertainer unfortunately for the young
Carl the assassination of President
Abraham Lincoln put on hold all forms of
public entertainment and he was forced
to find work as a bar keeper and a
teacher eventually returned to his home
in Vienna Oren's was reconciled with his
parents and was hired to work as a
draftsman on the construction of a steel
mill his elders had their doubts but he
was extraordinarily able and industrious
and he impressed them even further when
he developed a knack for sourcing steel
and iron during a period of economic
crisis it wasn't long before he was
making investments profiting from the
growth of the rails and finally making a
fortune off the 1878 war between Russia
and Turkey by the time Ludwig
Wittgenstein was born in 1889 his family
had money and influence they moved
through all the social circles of the
upper echelon of Vienna's cultural and
intellectual crowds and their wealth
only continued to grow at a rate that
allowed Carl to retire in 1898 at the
age of 51 theirs was a life of leisure
they amassed collections of art and
manuscripts furniture and porcelain and
calls siblings all 11 of them were just
as successful it was a family of
scientists and soldiers of great
thinkers of judges of patrons of the
Arts and doctors the Vidkun stein home
was a hustle and bustle of Viennese
culture and cars children grew up in a
home frequented by the likes of Sigmund
Freud Johannes Brahms and Karl Kraus
that's also during this time that Vidkun
Stein read one of the books that would
have a lifelong impact on him Otto
Weininger 1903 book sex and character
while it's still debated just how much
of an impact this book had it is
generally credited for introducing
Vidkun Stein to the idea that life
should be lived in an almost
single-minded pursuit of the creation of
a work of pure genius lofty aspirations
for sure but here
some of the names he grew up around it's
easy to see why he would be so
determined to achieve greatness and
immortality through its work but that
good fortune that shaped cars generation
did not extend to the next Ovid consign
would leave the family home to Cambridge
in 1911 and by then it already lived
through the deaths of several siblings
his oldest brother Hans headed off to
America Aaron disappeared in 1902 the
family believed he took his own life in
1904 the second oldest Rudy did the same
by drinking a glass of potassium cyanide
as a way of coping coal forbid the rest
of the family from ever mentioning
either of their names again and it was
an order that didn't just push an
already devastated family to the
breaking point it actually broke them
the relationship between the remaining
children and their parents was never the
same and it explained quite a bit about
what would happen later
even as a young man Ludvig victim Stein
suffered through the loss of his
brothers and it's worth taking a slight
aside here to address one of these
rumors that sounds so unlikely so
strange that it just has to be false
accepts in this case it's only partially
false historians and scholars have long
tried to figure out just what drove
Hitler's anti-semitic madness and
there's a single mention in mine camp
that goes like this I did meet one
Jewish boy who was treated by all of us
with caution but only because various
experiences had led us to doubt his
discretion and we did not particularly
trust him that's led to a lot of
speculation that Vidkun Stein was that
boy and he ended off Hitler did albeit
briefly attends the same school in Linz
it was the 1904 to 1905 school urines
it's a rewarding Theory not only would
both go on to be written about in the
history books but it would help make
sense of one of the biggest questions of
the Holocaust why Wittgenstein and his
family would feel the icy grip of the
hand of the Third Reich but that's for a
bit later in this story the first strike
against this story that Vidkun stein
inspired Hitler's rabid hatred of the
Jews is that for three generations the
Vidkun Stein's have been practicing
Roman Catholics and he didn't
necessarily identify as Jewish
even though baptismal records identified
three of his four grandparents as being
Jewish before their conversion and this
too is also going to be important and
there's an end
that quote that often gets emitted from
the conspiracy theories but neither I
nor the others had any thoughts on the
matter
it's generally believed that it wasn't
until much later that Hitler's
anti-semitism kicked into high gear and
it's worth noting that mainstream
history is pretty much cleared Vidkun
Stein of being the root cause of
Hitler's anti-semitism Wittgenstein's
education was as erratic as his father's
young life had been he didn't start in
philosophy in fact he started out about
as far from philosophy as possible after
studying mechanical engineering in
Berlin he switched to Aeronautics and
particularly the study of kites in 1908
that's also when he headed off to
Manchester in England and his work there
led him down the road to mathematics
finding himself pondering heavy
philosophical musings over the
foundations of mathematics as a whole he
sought out the mathematician and
philosopher goodlove freegan it was
Frigga who recommended that he speak
with Bertrand Russell and it was Russell
who saw the potential for great things
in the young students Vidkun Stein
sought the potential for great things in
himself - once asking Russell will you
please tell me whether I am a complete
idiot or not
when Russell asked him why he responded
with because if I have a complete idiot
I shall become an aeronaut bus if not I
shall become a philosopher
Russell instructed him to write a bit of
philosophical arguments and he did
Russell read just a single sentence and
told him no you mustn't become an errand
or Wittgenstein only spent a few years
at Cambridge and a year after meeting
Russell he had spent so much time and
effort in the pursuit of logic that
Russell declared there was nothing more
to teach him he said to that he was
difficult he would often show up in his
mentees rooms in the middle of the night
paced relentlessly and declare that when
he left he was going to kill himself
Russell wouldn't send him away and they
would sit in silence for hours finally
Russell asked him if he was pondering
the mysteries of logic or his sins and
he simply responded both and he took his
deep thoughts very seriously heading off
to Norway for months at a time to simply
think without the distractions of campus
life he built himself a wooden hut at
the edge of Ford and it was there that
he laid the groundwork for his beliefs
that facts can be shared through what he
called logical forms
Wittgenstein left Cambridge in 1913 it
was a year marked by the passing of his
father he quickly gave away his
inheritance and this was on the eve of
World War one the following year he
voluntarily enlisted in the Austrian
army and far from being scared his
writing suggests that he was looking
forward to the war and to the
opportunity of getting up close and
personal with death he wrote in one
journal only death gives life its
meaning and first he did spend quite a
bit of the war well out of harm's way
when it came time for him to volunteer
for a posting though he chose one of the
most dangerous he headed out into
no-man's land and manned and lookout
post at the front of the Austrian line
throughout the war Wittgenstein continue
to rise both philosophy and to those
that he had met and studied with a
Cambridge his admiration of Russell and
Russell's appreciation of his intellect
perhaps predictably began to go downhill
he was as difficult as he was brilliant
that relationship turned into one of
bickering and a regular theme in Vidkun
Stein's journals was one of lament he
was heartbroken at the responses he was
getting from his fellow philosophers
even if he survived the roar he wrote he
wondered about the usefulness of his
work and worried that no one would
understand it or be able to grasp how
important it was
he wrote constantly during the war
compiling notes what would eventually be
turned into his Tractatus
logico-philosophicus
door in translation his logical
philosophical treatise it would be the
only book he would publish in his
lifetime and scholars that look back
over the work in context of what he was
going through at the time say it was
undoubtedly influenced by the war and
shaped by both his time in relative
safety behind the front lines and in the
thick of the fighting it was at this
time too that he read Tolstoy the gospel
in brief and and something of an
epiphany he read it again and again as
he wrote his works on logic work that
eventually led in the direction of
combining ethics religion and aesthetics
with logic at the heart of the matter
was that all of these topics couldn't be
satisfactorily explained with words they
needed to be shown confusing absolutely
and he said so himself when he wrote a
friends with this insight if only you do
not try to utter what is unalterable
then nothing gets lost
but the unutterable will be unutterably
contained in what has been uttered and
that sums up how difficult a fit can
Stein can be to read much less
understands
in 1918 he was captured and spent the
remainder of the war in an Italian POWs
camp here - he kept writing and when he
was released he published his seminal
work something it up briefly is just
impossible but it's worth noting that
not only did Bertrand Russell write the
original introduction for it
but if it can Steen was fairly disgusted
with what he thought was a complete
misunderstanding of the text at the
heart of it is the idea that the world
consists of objects in turn combinations
of objects results in what he described
as a state of affairs and facts were
ultimately states of affairs that
existed in the real worlds and could be
described via those objects basically
Pitkin Stein had a reason for exploring
all of this and he was trying to
construct a system that would allow for
a framework with which to divide the
world into two areas
sense and nonsense interestingly some of
the things he defined a senseless under
his system were things like mathematics
and logic while nonsense was something
else completely that was the idea that
something is completely devoid of
meaning and well he had a lot of time on
his hands during the war considering
that even the professionals in the world
of philosophy have trouble describing
his work and tracing the leaps and
bounds he makes in logic we're just
going to leave this one right here and
that's exactly what Vidkun Stein did -
after the publication of his work he was
completely convinced that there were
simply no more problems left to solve
he quit philosophy and took on a less
complicated life spending nearly a
decade travelling around Vienna taking
odd jobs from gardening to architecture
and occasionally teaching that
particular vocation came to an abrupt
and rather brutal end in one Austrian
mountain village where he struck a
student so hard he knocked the boy
unconscious his immediate resignation
followed along with a long bout of
depression fortunately for the world of
philosophy he was ultimately exposed to
the philosophical musings of the Vienna
circle a group of mathematicians
scientists and philosophers who met
regularly through the 1920s thanks to
them he realized that there was still
quite a few problems worthy of his
attention
[Music]
the realization that there were bigger
better and deeper philosophical problems
that remained unsolved led to vidcon
Stein's returned to Cambridge in 1929 at
the time he wasn't the most famous
member of his family that honor went to
his brother Paul who had always had an
innate gift for music and was known as
an outstanding concert pianist he too
was in World War 1 and suffered an
injury that should have been devastating
he lost Nam
but even as his brother wandered Vienna
looking for a point to his continued
existence on earth Paul worked with some
of the area's greatest composers to
create music for the piano that required
only a left hand to play as the world
slowly inch towards yet another conflict
that would engulf the globe the Austrian
brothers found themselves in perhaps the
best place they could be on the outside
in 1939 Vidkun Stein was elected to one
of the top positions in Cambridge and it
helps give him something of an infinite
value British citizenship the timing
couldn't have been better the years
Hitler had been working on reuniting
Germany and Austria there was a failed
coup a treaty with Italy the promise to
protect Austria from German aggression
and even attempts by Mussolini's Italian
troops to interfere with the annexation
it happens anyway and in 1938 Austria
was absorbed into the Third Reich had
other devastating impacts on the Vidkun
Stein family remember they had been long
practicing Christians buying this time
but what was done in practice and what
was written on paper in their case were
two different things there was still a
record of those three Jewish
grandparents and conversion or no
conversion that meant they were still
considered Jewish under the Nuremberg
Laws dictating racial purity none of
them were able to vote or do seemingly
petty actions like sit on a park bench
for all of the siblings it was dangerous
Paul in particular a musical celebrity
of 1930s Vienna was deeply troubled he
was no longer allowed to work in the
field of the arts and more troubling he
was in violation of another law section
two of the Nuremberg Laws for the
protection of German blood and German
honor he wasn't married but it was the
father of two children and their mother
was German had they been a normal
everyday sort of family they may have
been able to flee without attracting the
attention of the Third Reich but they
were one of the wealthiest in Europe and
what followed was a comp
that of legal and financial maneuvering
that didn't really work out for anyone
in 1939 the two surviving victims dined
brothers brother Kurt it also committed
suicide at the end of World War one
appeals their case based on the fact
that a single grandparents was the
bastard child of a Gentile along with
the appeal went a significant bribe they
handed over most of their fortune to the
Nazi regime but in turn their sisters
harmine and Helena were granted
half-breed status and were safe from the
relentless march of the Nazi war machine
it's undeniable that the victim stein
fortune aided the advancement of the
Third Reich and if there was ever a
philosophical question that needed
debate what was the true price paid for
the safety of the victim Stein's sisters
was it worth it should they have paid
and would you have it's a question that
can only be answered by those faced with
the impossible question it was Paul who
was the driving force behind the
decision to transfer much of the
family's fortune from a trust in a Swiss
bank accounts to the coffers of the
Third Reich he the oldest sibling would
be the last to die and after he made the
decision to save them he would never see
any of his siblings again for his part
during the war Ludwig Wittgenstein
worked as a porter at Guy's Hospital in
London and here is where we touched on a
few of the things that historians and
scholars have never truly been able to
answer Wittgenstein s writings make it
clear that there are some unresolved
issues simmering away in the background
and it's a fascinating glimpse into the
mind of a man so obsessed with logic the
one it's never quite clear whether or
not he considered himself Jewish
occasionally he did call himself a
Jewish thinker while at other times he
condemned what he believed was a
misrepresentation of his ancestry
similarly Vidkun stein found himself
fighting an almost constant battle with
the sexuality at the time it wasn't just
taboo to be gay it was illegal and it
would have been met with outrage at the
very least it's impossible to tell what
kind of effect barring that sort of
burden had on his writing and his
philosophy but it's also been suggested
that he gravitated toward teachings like
Freud's who suggested people were
universally attracted to both sexes it
was an idea that was safely mainstream
and may have been a comforting bit of
modern thought there was another
constant and
lying theme throughout not just VidCon
Stein's writings but through the Diaries
and journals of those who knew him he
spoke often of his thoughts of suicide
told those closest to him about his
sense of unrelenting shame and
loneliness and of the possibility of
becoming just another one of his
siblings to take that final step
his friends David Hume persons wrote
this heartbreaking glimpse into his
psyche he had suffered from terrific
loneliness for the past nine years that
he had thought of suicide then and he
felt ashamed of never daring to kill
himself he told me that all his life
there had hardly been a day in which he
had not at one time or another thought
of suicide as a possibility but consign
did ultimately die young but he did not
take his own life for two decades he
struggled to put together another book
but always the perfectionist he
consistently failed in putting together
something that would live up to the
vision of what he believed it should be
his later works were only published
posthumously and he didn't live to see
the influence that he had on 20th
century philosophy in 1947 Vidkun Stein
resigned from his post to Cambridge much
like he had once retreated to the quiet
solitude of the Fords of Norway he later
did the same and headed for the remote
wilds of Connemara in Ireland the
peaceful solitude was not to last in
1949 he was diagnosed with prostate
cancer and by 1951 he knew he didn't
have long to live he moved into a home
with his doctor and died on April the
29th 1951 reportedly his last words were
tell them I've had a wonderful life so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and don't
forget to subscribe brand new videos
just like this every day of the week for
more from me why not subscribe to
another channel I do called Geographics
this channel is all about people that
channel is all about places link to it
below and thank you for watching
[Music]